the taekwondo produced the first
big shock for team gb jade jones the
two-time olympic champion from north
wales
was beaten in her first outing by a
player
on the refugee team jade has done so
much for taekwondo
but tokyo will not be the crowning
moment
there were fine margins in the pool max
litchfield went
so so close in the men's medley a few
tenths of a second away from a medal
he finished fourth in rio and joined
fourth here
adam petey though cruised to another win
in his semi-final
the mustache is gone and he'll go for
gold and his own world record tomorrow
joining him james will be from glasgow
who also made it through to the final
andy murray has pulled out from the
men's singles tennis with a muscle
strain he said
i'm really disappointed at having to
withdraw but the medical staff have
advised me against playing in both
events
so i've made the difficult decision to
withdraw from the singles
and focus on playing doubles
in the hockey the gb women are the
defending champions but opened up with a
2-1 defeat against germany
great britain will play south africa
next
lizzie diegnon goes in the women's road
race today surfing is underway
and street skateboarding is also making
its debut in the games
but it's not yet time for 13 year old
skye brown for team gb
she's in the park skateboarding
competition that's later in these games